one of the best ways I've heard people
talk about this is everyone understands
the concept of land right they're not
making more of it and owning land has
value if you can break that model to
urban that model to understand digital
land right or digital property and you
say hey there's only 21 million acres
right and you can buy one right now for
eighty nine hundred dollars
right do you think there's gonna be
worth more or less in the future right
yeah and and by the way look just like
land
there's price fluctuations sometimes
certain areas there it's more valuable
or less valuable right but generally
over long periods of time the scarce
assets rise in price and that has to do
with one there being more desirability
but also to exactly the currency being
devalued against the scarce asset right
meaning that the US dollar or whatever
is is losing purchasing power and so it
takes more of those dollars to buy that
same asset and when people hear that I
think that kind of clicks and say oh
wait that is interesting explain that
more yes so we've got so you just
mentioned two forces there that that
basically are inversely correlated but
they drive each other which is the the
devaluing of the current currency that
we're using to price this new thing but
also the the scarcity and the fixed
supply of this new thing which can't you
know once people understand that it
can't be printed or you can't make more
of it you know the the common sense
thing is all right will
infinite finite you know that that's
where more value is and then you've also
got the the third piece like yeah you
know let's argue that someone could
create something that is finite in
supply but it's completely useless now
that that probably won't accrue value so
like if we look at Bitcoin it is
fundamentally useful you know it's
digital divisible portable it's got all
these sorts of incredible primitives
another one that I was discussing
yesterday with someone was and this is
something I've experienced firsthand as
a FinTech company for us for example to
be able to accept credit card payments
to help people buy Bitcoin then I am
about two and a half or three weeks
through a due diligence process with so
much paperwork so much checks so much
garbage that like I can't even explain
to you how much time and effort has been
wasted just to give us as a company the
permission to help somebody buy a
product called Bitcoin like if in a
world where Bitcoin is of functional
money that permission does need to be
you know taste like you don't you don't
have any of that so all of that friction
all of that wasted time energy resources
[ __ ] that doesn't actually add value to
anything it's gone like you literally
throw that out like I think even Jack
Dorsey was talking about it he was
saying you know Square is a fin tech
company but it's fundamentally unable to
operate like an Internet company because
of all of these jurisdictional limits
that are exist because of the current
fragmented you know horse and buggy
financial system that we have like
Bitcoin is completely an entirely
different beast it's that I mean coming
back to Peter Thiel ism writers that
it's the zero to one it looks nothing
like the existing financial system and
that therein lies the innovation it's
not you know all these FinTech bros
running around trying to you know
augment the existing financial system
and make some things faster and
you know build some new API nose that's
right that's all cool and well you know
it's it's cute basically but it's not a
fundamental reinvention it's nothing new
it's not it's not an iPhone versus a
Nokia banana phone like it's it's a it's
a complete reinvention of money payments
and all in the one stack and that I
think when you layer that on top of the
the land argument and so you've got this
thing which is not ten times but a
hundred times more superior and then you
say it's finite in supply and then you
say that you can show that this other
thing that we're using at the moment is
not only infinite in supply but it's
also devaluing it's broken and all this
sort of [ __ ] like you you literally have
to be a maniac or a [ __ ] or ignorant or
I don't know what you have to be to sort
of dismiss Bitcoin as a scam like like I
literally don't get it anymore like it I
see no reason why someone shouldn't have
not only you know some of the wealth in
Bitcoin but any wealth that they
actually value in Bitcoin simple is that